Vsauce!
Kevin here.
Christmas: Rioting, getting drunk and demanding
food from rich people.
The Twelfth Night of Christmas in Tudor-era
England reversed class roles, with peasants
being served by nobles - a tradition stemming
from the ancient Roman festival of Saturnalia.
Even through the early 1800s, Christmas Day
in New York City saw the poor getting drunk
and rioting against the elite - extorting
food and drink and vandalizing their homes.
The Santa Claus we know today was developed
in part to make the focus of the holiday giving
gifts to children, which kept the lower class
home with their families - and not out knocking
down doors for figgy pudding.
The model for Santa was Saint Nicholas - a
4th century Christian saint famous for secret
gift-giving - like putting coins in the shoes
left out for him.
And the name Santa Claus is a phonetic alteration
of the German Sankt Niklaus.
After the Protestant Reformation, veneration
of saints fell out of favor throughout much
of Europe, so secret gift-giving and behavior-monitoring
fell upon folklore companions of Saint Nicholas
like Belsnickel - a ragged-looking man clad
in fur who threatened naughty kids with a
stick.
An 1821 poem -- the first contemporary description
of Santa Claus -- reveals that he left a birch
rod in children's stockings so parents could
discipline them.
That poem was called “The Children’s Friend.”
And suddenly coal sounds pretty good.
Hanging stockings at Christmas evolved from
the practice of leaving carrots in boots near
the chimney to feed the Norse mythological
god Odin’s flying horse.
Odin came down the chimney or fire hole and,
in exchange for the horse food, left candy.
Mistletoe has been revered for millennia because
it stays a vibrant green through the winter.
It also grows on oak trees, which were sacred
to Ancient Druids - with the likely derivation
of the word Druid being “One with knowledge
of the Oak”.
Druids thought of kissing under mistletoe
as a love charm that promoted fertility because
mistletoe contained the soul of the beloved
oak tree... and also that it was the oak tree's
genitals.
And as always - thanks for watching!